[Music]
all right we're rolling we hating uh
blah blah Rachel Rachel Jew
Wendy Cummings just found out I'm gonna
have to
really big deal give me an action first
you got to give it to me okay one two
three okay that's not how action is
called but it's good to know that
there's no man left in this world one
two three action
that was like a guy his first day on a
porn set straight out of Pensacola just
got to Burbank and they're like you need
to call Action one please say that every
time you come
Feinstein's here this is a delight thank
you for coming what a dream
thank you and you gave me a Blazer
usually I look like a freshly divorced
real estate agent but not today today no
you look like a freshly married for the
second time real estate agent thank you
God bounce back from the divorce yeah I
look like the kind of woman that would
set like hand a man a matchbook at a bar
or something
but today I'm fucking I'm I'm somebody
new who I am you know you have you have
big Johnny Depp's lawyer energy yes
Camille Vasquez I am taking charge
I'm angry and I'm ready to get even with
men I have like a lot I look like I have
a lot of books up that say things like
you know like all the way to rape and
back again you know like just like all
my books are just like you know letting
go of your rage you know also you have
big 90s Matchmaker energy yes like
Matchmaker with a reality show yes you
know I used to watch
um I actually took advice from uh
millionaire matchmakers Patty's
stingler she told me that men hang out
at steakhouses and I you guys I went and
hung out at steakhouses to try to meet a
guy and I don't think I realized how
actively embarrassing that was
Chris or like McCormick and schmuck how
was that I think it depends on the level
of scenes there's a lot of levels of
Steakhouse you can get out back all the
way up to the
I don't know what are they what's the
there is a sadness to like winking at a
guy at a Del Frisco's you know there's
just a real dark archaic throbbing
sadness to that like the bars at
steakhouses I feel like it's like the
wine glasses are like
like I'm rebounding tonight like it's
those giant like Fishbowl wine glasses
where it's like half full of Pinot grige
yeah you're not just ready to make one
bad decision you want to make a cocktail
of dramatic errors in your life yeah I
and I don't think I realize that that is
not something I should Loosely tell
people so I was just like proud like
proud of it I had to be taken aside I
would be like at the cellar and I'd be
like I gotta get a you know I got a
steakhouse after this because I'm trying
to find a guy and like one of my friends
was like I wouldn't like announce that
so loosely like she's like that's it's
proof that you're in a sort of a dark um
alarming place okay and I'm sure that
that person that judge you was holding
their phone swiping on Tinder yeah as if
that was not a disgusting humiliating uh
Rock Bottom yeah and it's hard when you
do stand-up to meet a guy on like an app
you know what I mean because then they
try to tell you jokes and it's weird and
I started dating someone recently that I
met in person
and the level of um
Panic amongst my friends who were like
you know because they're like wait a
second you just met him in person and
like it because you know 10 I don't know
like five six years ago you'd be like
you're just gonna meet up with some guy
you met on the internet like are you
insane like yeah you're right and now
you know and then then we'd be like well
there's nothing crazier than like
meeting someone at a bar and then
getting in their car yeah what's the
difference honestly between texting
without having like fun loving banter
with them first they could kill you
either way
even once you're married the white
picket fence in 20 years you're getting
killed I mean regardless a man's gonna
kill you and he's probably gonna be your
husband that's gonna make a suit out of
your skin and yeah and with our
personalities like it's gonna happen
yeah somebody's somebody's had it with
me yeah let me ask you so it's gonna be
some Mississippi fucking guy online like
some guy off YouTube that some kind of
Reddit thread it's gonna be like I've
had it with her shit and her man voice
and who she thinks she is also there's
like the other flip side that's like my
self-esteem is so low that I don't feel
like any man's gonna kill me because I'm
like I'm not like worth going to jail
for no I know I've never had a guy get
real like passionate about me manner
like I'd have to go missing for weeks
before my husband would look for me like
no one looks for brunettes oh really no
interesting you watch Nancy Grace none
of the none of the missing they're all
blonde no man has ever like put his hand
on my lower back and like led me
protectively through a room like no
people are nobody's like tucked me in a
car and referred to me as precious cargo
they're always just like you good to get
there when a fight breaks out a guy will
like hide behind me as a human shield I
mean but if it's a blonde which by the
way may I with all these missing blonde
girls did you see on People magazine
JonBenet Ramsay was on the cover of
People magazine recently which by the
way let the letter dot let her arrest
yes peace y'all because it was her eight
they were like it would have been her
18th birthday which is like so fucking
weird disgusting I mean there was like
some like deep web like countdown of
when JonBenet would have turned 18 or
something or you mean just like guys
that were waiting to want to have
hypothetical
to start beating off to her imaginary
not murdered 18 year old self that is so
so so alarming and then for a magazine
to like put her on the cover like she
would have been 18 today it's like did
they make her face 18. no I don't think
so either I don't know but I also I'm
like so I don't know if it's just having
like a parent die or something or being
grief I also went off birth control
which I am like now's not the time I
guess in America to be like anti-birth
control I guess what's going on but like
I you know when you're on birth control
like your body thinks it's pregnant were
you on birth control before I was never
in birth control and I always did the
pull out method but I thought it was
called pull it out method and my friends
were like it's called pull out I was
like I would say that like real calmly
like I'm on the confidently like I'm
like I'm on the pull it out method
that's visually very hard to wait I mean
I don't understand yeah guess you're
right that's why it's wrong but there's
a couple of like adages or like you get
no phrases that you get wrong for so
long like um yeah I was saying best
thing since life spread yeah so like two
years ago and someone was like what did
you just say and I was like it's like
the best thing since life spread and
they're like it's sliced spread and I
was like wait say it again the best
thing since life's bread
what did you think life's spread loaf of
bread I like the body of Christ I don't
know oh that's great no wonder bread
because and then someone said it's like
sliced bread I'm like why is sliced
spreads so much better than life's
brother yeah it's a little more like
awesome I say things that are like
alarmingly I don't know I have very
little alarmingly dumb I think I get
credit for being smart because I'm
sarcastic and Jewish but I know nothing
if you're like a Jew that's kind of
sarcastic people assume that you have
some some amount of information a
hauntingly low amount I just found out
I'm half Jewish what am I in for oh yeah
so how did you find that out well my mom
died and then all the family secrets
come up you know because they had
changed their names my mom's dad and my
dad's mom maybe they were trans I don't
know Jewish or trans well it's hard to
tell it's the same and then I kind of I
don't know why I feel like it was kind
of weird to say like no I feel like I'm
Jewish because you know I'm like
annoying and loud and like you know my
stomach hurts a lot I was like I always
like thought I was in a way that felt a
little bit like I like at the time where
I just moved to Hollywood and I was like
I'm Jew like I know how to do this yeah
like it comes very naturally to me so
wait did the family like back in history
did some ancestor like hide and tuck
away their juness or like if I mean
knowing my family it was probably more
like like my dad and mom like had a
secret family it wasn't like about
somebody cheated on somebody it wasn't
about not wanting to be Jewish it was
more like uh my name is um you know
Allen
blue
just to not to be able to pick up chicks
and yeah exactly like so I don't know if
it was I mean do you really need to keep
hiding from you know the Nazis in
Virginia and Texas yes in the 50s I
don't know maybe I remember reading like
an old book when I was in high school
and um it was like some Russian novel
maybe somebody would be be really smart
and actually know what book I read
people often tell me what I'm trying to
say they're like here's what I think you
want to tell us but there was some book
that I read I think it was like some
Russian novel and the guy was explaining
that somebody was dark it was like
foreshadowing sort of using
foreshadowing to explain that this
person was going to be sort of an evil
character and then the way they
explained that was by saying he wasn't a
good man he was said to have a Jew
cousin in the North
and I was like that is the greatest
phrase I've ever heard he was said to
him Jews don't go to the north first of
all yes the flights are too expensive
and I also like that just the fact that
he had a shoe cousin in the north not
even him himself but that he was had a
Jew cousin already he was up to Sinister
just sort of daunting things I can't so
have I jump around a lot on this podcast
and I feel like I've wanted to have you
on for so long and like having you on I
just I feel like I've spent so much time
in comedy like being a fan of yours like
wanting to be your friend and like I've
never known I'm feeling your Blazer
what's that I know I feel like we're
like every and every time you come over
I'm so weird I'm like trying to have
like makeup for lost time with you and
have like a mini slumber party with you
for 20 minutes that's my favorite thing
to do I know
oh my God I just am like I've wanted to
be friends with you so long that now I'm
like we're sisters I have had so much
fun today but I'm actually really glad
that we didn't get like I feel like I
know you more recently like for real
like you're in New York I'm L.A whatever
I think there's always like when you
tour a lot like something I love so much
about you is how hardcore you tour I do
the same but like I think that like
there's a lot of female Comics we kind
of like Circle each other and there's
like uh I don't know there was such a
scarcity complex for so long it was
definitely like you know my head I
didn't think anyone ever has liked me
you know ever but also just I think I
had this darwinian instinct to not try
to pursue any kind of you know
relationship with you too soon because I
feel like I was just like I'm not ready
yet like I don't I'm glad it's now
because it's fascinating because to me
like yeah you were on the roasts and
stuff like you you know like the com the
big Comedy Central roast yeah I just
assumed that everybody either doesn't
um know who I am or uh yeah it doesn't
uh care for me yeah well no I mean I
think for me and then I kind of I don't
know I have you know we all have
insecurities whatever I'll just splatter
on about mine but I'm kind I'm actually
because for the longest time I kind of
was like
I want to be friends with her and why
aren't we friends and like I did I say
something wrong did I do something wrong
you know all the billion things that you
like make up in your head which is so
ridiculous which is yeah the narcissism
of like I'm a piece of shit in the
center of the universe yeah or like I'd
see you I'd see you on lineups I'd be
like should I come early and like say hi
Oh my God I get really Starstruck by
like I think female Comics whatever
comedians who I because I've always just
been trying to like find sisters and
chosen family but they're coming up as a
female comic it was just like so like
wild and
I always sometimes feel like when you
know there's two female Comics you're
like we have to be friends but like in
what other business do you have to force
a friendship right you know kind of
thing and I and I never want to be like
this like unctuous like we're both
comics and only like 10 people can
relate to our life so like let's be
besties it's like that's an like
annoying so I think um now I'm kind of
just like psyched that we're becoming
friends now because I feel like I'm at
my most um
we grew up mentally functional yes me
too like we got some tools yeah
I'm not like scared I'm gonna say the
wrong thing I'm not like it's also the
comics like it's It's tricky because I'm
like I'm not that funny a person when
I'm not doing stand up and you know I
never know because some Comics want to
be doing bits all the time and I'm just
like not that guy so I don't know I just
I feel like yeah when I first started it
is better that we know each other now
because I feel like when I first started
I was like just just so mentally ill
like I was I could barely dress myself I
was and I was just dating these guys at
the time that was like just you know
insane like wild emergency alcohol swear
to go same same whatever I wasn't on
stage Whitney I was in a port authority
bar just trying to collect a drug just
like some hot Dusty construction worker
being like just come on just get in the
car we've been here for six hours I was
um have you had you gotten to the point
where you were learning Spanish to fight
with drug dealers no I learned I learned
a couple good phrases I was in most of
my 20s kind of unconscious and
um uh obsessively I mean I think that it
was an adrenaline addiction uh first and
foremost but also the same way that you
know
alcoholics are addicted to alcohol or
not yeah I was addicted to drug addicts
yeah addicted to rescuing them fixing me
too and also also the apology is a real
rush because he would just be like do
something monstrous just like some
horrific wild night of insane horseshit
yeah and then the next day I remember
this one guy was dating this like
construction worker this just this
red-eyed hot like you kind of look like
Paul Newman but he was just like unwell
he's in retard but you were literally
dating retards guys in helmets you
literally were guys that were helmet
yeah it wasn't good and I remember and
then he would end it but then he would
do something insane just wild insane
horseshit and he would start glaring at
a certain hour of the night he would
have like some sort of glare off and I'm
like and the people get more and more
ridiculous I'm like you're glaring at
like Virginia at a Port Authority bottom
like she's an old Widow what beef could
you have that's my favorite when someone
that is drunk it's like it's like all
great everything's good we're dancing on
the bar and then when it goes like it
turns dark it's like this motherfucker
in the car they just lock onto somebody
either it's sort of like they're time
traveling where someone's triggered them
into their like childhood circumstance
it becomes their dad their ex-wife their
ex-girlfriend and they're like yeah this
is gonna be a fight like for no reason
yeah that would be like there would be
this weird kind of like sort of glare
offs that he would have and then and
then it would just spin out and he would
be like you think you know me yeah I'm
like all right you think you're so much
better than me the guy's like yeah I
knew actually I didn't until you just
said that
this is going to show you how much
little like what's the thing you have in
your nose but you're in the hospital you
know the little oh it's like a oxygen
yeah oxygen thing I'm like leave
Virginia alone let her fucking enjoy her
fucking chin she's got an oxygen tube in
her nose for fuck's sake why and you're
like a jacked construction worker what
beef do you have why do you think you
did gravitated towards that because I
have a couple theories about my number
one I felt like if I was with someone
that was inebriated or on some kind of
drug number one I could rescue them save
them it was a self-esteem hit for me
because I felt like I was able to you
you know um I Define myself through my
like productivity to others I needed
like I needed to be like needed almost
like pathologically so it made me also I
didn't have to focus on myself I had
this martyr complex you know it's like
I've talked about this a lot being in
adult children of alcoholic program it's
like you know uh the 3ms I needed to
like mother micromanage and Martyr
myself you know so that I didn't have to
deal with being in a true like it's a
way to avoid intimacy ultimately because
this person is always unconscious and so
I can kind of have like this imaginary
you're right relationship I also get the
adrenaline hit and then I get to be a
victim which is yeah I have you know a
very safe place to be you know of like
and I also quite frankly thought it was
all I deserved and it was really
familiar like you know cleaning up after
an alcoholic going through that cycle of
like you know never knowing where you
stand and never knowing what mood
they're going to be in like that was
what my childhood was so it's like for
better that and then if I was in
something kind of calm with someone that
you know didn't you know have those
addictions number one it would get very
boring very fast
um because I was just wired to just need
that much adrenaline and and I would
have anxiety and something that was for
lack of a better word like healthy and
calm because I felt like I was always
waiting for the shoe to drop it was like
the Damocles sword had been hung and I
would rather just be in chaos than
things be calm and be like chaos is
coming I just don't know when like that
was just too stressful for me and I also
think I like I thought it was hot like
it's like tattoos cigarettes like yeah
exciting now I value first and foremost
like self-control and restraint it's hot
to me but someone that like couldn't
control themselves I think on some level
thought that was like Alpha yeah and
meanwhile it's just alarming and dark
and so it's really sad yeah and very
expensive yeah you're right but I do
think um I for me definitely like I
relate with uh all of that and I think
that I it is it's funny because it's
like I like to think that I choose I
used to think I choose these like kind
of emotionally unavailable just just
insanely distant men that also are prone
to um sudden bursts of rage and
strangers but but you also it's like I
don't it's the same thing it's like but
but it's your intimacy issue because it
always comes back to you it's like why
are you choosing people that you
couldn't possibly you know it probably
also grossed me out when someone gazed
in my eyes like gently I'm like yeah
beat it I don't want that you know like
so that it was definitely that issue and
then also I think like for me when I was
like in my early 20s when I started
stand up I was still a nanny full-time
and bartending and stuff I already
bartending in New York yeah I was
bartending in New York and you came from
and I came from Maryland Bethesda and I
moved to New York with this guy in his
band which is so weird because I went to
high school in Bethesda yeah we both
went to school near each other went to
Whitman I would say yeah when I went to
Walter Johnson and some little Quaker
school and then yeah and then I moved to
New York did you have Quaker no they
just sent me to Quaker school because I
was failing so badly in my public school
that there was like some one Quaker
School called Thornton friends that
everyone called um snorting fiends
because that's like where they said the
bad kids and I thought I like got in
there there I was like wow I was
accepted and somebody else was like no
it's like a last resort kind of thing
what is what was was Quaker was it to
have curriculum it was just because no
other schools would take me and there
was one small school in like Colesville
Maryland that would take you know just
kids that were um did like a it's it's
closed down now but they did like an
aggressive amount of whippets and you
know the kids were just a problem I by
the way I just I'm asking because I am
in the market for a religion yeah a
Quaker is kind of satisfying it's like
you all just take everybody takes their
turns it's like uh yeah it's it's like
similar to like a 12-step program you
know like it because I mean I'm just
making I'm talking to my ass but
somebody will probably correct me in the
comments but they still believe uh they
seek experience God directly it's the
same shit I guess I thought they had
like a whole like don't they even make
butter or some shit I think that might
be Amish people that make butter okay
maybe quicker people are Amish people I
don't know um in the 17th century bar
two distinct groups how dare you with
different interpretations the Bible
characters and brothers I yeah it's a
little bit the dreamish people are the
ones that churn things the dressers are
a little dumpy for me yeah the dresses
are homely they're jacked up stress is
the guidance of the Holy Spirit okay I
fuck with ghosts dude the Holy Ghost
like I would fuck with a ghost as my
Quaker is good maybe they have like are
they into windmills or is that honest
people I feel like they're uh five
beliefs of Quakers truth is continually
revealed
uh what as long as you're not reading
the news it just sounds like something a
guy says when they're cheating on you or
they don't want to admit it like that
you'll be revealed like something you're
gonna have to think about long enough so
they can walk out of the room and go
fuck some more
that's my favorite no it's like my
favorite is what a guy is like doing
something shady and they'll repeat the
question you asked in the answer to my
time to make up their lie you'll be like
hey where were you till two in the
morning they're like where was I
until two in the morning that's what
that guy used to say yes when I would
come in he was always like just he was
like you love to start an argument you
loved and I'm like what I didn't say you
were drunk but he's clearly just
throbbingly drunk he'd be like oh you
love to say this you love to excuse me
please
and then just softly fall into the
carpet just forward off his bed just his
dumb head would tip over but I moved in
with him you know what I'm kind of
problem you're making me realize
I wanted to be an actress so early you
just blew my mind and like I saw like
and I want to know how you got started
because it's like I think people ask but
they don't really ask on like a a more
uh granular level of way before we even
had the concept of stand up or whatever
like when I was a kid I remember looking
at the TV and seeing commercials and
these like happy families and
commercials and I'd be like I want to be
in that that's where the happy families
are I gotta get in the box like from
such an early age I was like I'm gonna
be in commercials and like we would like
literally like you know when you would
um uh go on like a road trip as a kid
and you would see a billboard on the
side of the road that would say like
McDonald's 10 miles whatever like yeah
five b and there would be a kid like
eating a hamburger and you know my
sister and everyone else would be like
oh can we go to McDonald's and then I
would look at the billboard I would not
see anything about the exit I would be
like how did why is that kid on there
like I could do that like why aren't I
on there that's cool but see that's
that's something that I also feel like
that's a little thing inside of all the
rest of everything that that you know I
think like that are successful but it's
I mean it's pathological because I was
alone a lot as a kid I had a lot of like
app I was like very feral like an
absence of attention a lot of neglect
there was a lot of alcoholic you know
chaos but when I I also went out a way
out for you too it's like if I could get
up on that billboard and get the fuck
out of here totally just sort of like
that kid looks happy he just looks so
clean and he's eating a burger and like
yeah like I wasn't old enough to know
because I was like that Burger's like
perfect the ones we get are all nasty
like I want to be in that box you know
and and then um I started when I was
alone like I would not know if you did
any shit like this when you were a kid I
would eat as if I was in a commercial
yes you know like I would like eat this
I would like look in a certain direction
and I would like roll up cold cuts and
like bite them like yes how they did in
the commercial so not so then when I saw
those I was like I'm like really good at
that like I would always try to think of
like things that there's like some waspy
girl that I was really you know jealous
of just some girl she was like sprinkled
with Christ and sunshine and shit you
know just like some just clean girl it's
funny that you mention other people's
things because I was always so jealous
of other people's things because I would
get the same things as another girl and
my things would just become foul so
quickly they'd just be full of debris we
get the same thing I remember going over
my friend's house and we we went we got
some food together in the wa at the Y
and I got these little package of
cookies and she got her little cookies
and then she fucking had one and then
curled them in this way that I would
never cross something like she like
organized half of the package and I just
like stuffed them in my face like some
sort of fucking wolf with rabies or
something and they were gone and then I
asked her later I was just staring at
her cookies because they just even her
cookies like just the way she'd fucking
carefully put the package down was just
like I was
foul I feel like she has um OCD
definitely uh tried to hang herself on a
doorknob in the last five years I mean
that does feel like a or I want to like
like uh leave me alone for 10 minutes in
the woods with that girl's mom like why
you know like I remember when I go to
sleepovers at other kids houses I would
always give them headlights so I wasn't
allowed to go on sleepovers because I
had such bad head lice as a kid
different conversation my parents would
never clean the freaking you remember
rid yes you would have to use that
shampoo yeah burn your scalp off and
then uh I would get these like
contusions on my scalp like so traumatic
and then that I guess makes the bugs
like your scalp more because there's
like
yeah I would have like scabs and stuff
like they tried to like cut my hair
really short but I also like didn't have
like hair brushes like I don't know like
we just my house is very hair is such
like a I used to steal other girls
hairbrushes because they would have
these beautiful hair brushes and I just
had like a fork or whatever right you
know I was like The Little Mermaid just
brushing my hair with a fork and then so
you can't take other kids brushes that's
like how you get lice I mean I had
lights for like two years but I remember
going
um uh what was that what was I saying
about going over to someone's house I
can't remember but wanting other
people's things and going other people's
houses um I I don't know but I relate so
much I always wanted other girls things
um and then I think I think it's like
like going back to that that like so
much earlier about like okay when I
started I used to this is so psycho but
like the things we did to disassociate
or like cope with what we were going
through as kids where it was like if you
go like oh it was overeating you know
that girl may be in her needing to
organize
um I would interview myself
like I would I would like pretend like
Oprah was interviewing me because in my
head
it was like I've gotten through it yeah
you know what I mean it's like yeah and
I was it's like I've done no interviews
yes I've related to that I'd be like you
know my childhood was hard but like it
helped me do this and this and it made
me stronger like I was already on some
like I'm gonna get through this dude I'm
gonna get a book deal and like overcome
but I do feel like that kind of
visualizing is important it was some
like accidental manifestation exercise
there's like a glorious side of quote
where she says dreaming is a form of
planning and I always think about that
quote I'm like yeah yeah dreaming is a
formal because you could you imagine
that you can't do it you know what I
mean but but I definitely think that
like um I relate also with a with a hair
thing too because I used to go to school
with my hair dripping down my back
because I somehow didn't deal with
drying it properly I feel like you and I
are someone I feel like I had a very
busy busy parents like I was the one
like I never had the permission slip
signed yeah oh lunch yo my mom worked at
Bloomingdale's but I would get those
little brown bags from Bloomingdale's
and my lunch was always wet like it was
always all kids had these these great
lunches and mine was like so I was just
so embarrassed all the time like were
your school photos everyone's were like
perfect you look at mine and I just
jacked up just so jacked up just like an
animal and I think that's also part of
the reason that I would deal with these
insane guys is because when I was when I
first moved to New York if you had a job
and your apartment was organized like I
don't care if you were just like a wild
emergency like Coke addict like to me
then you were better than me because
like I'm like my room like my room is
disgusting I remember I met this woman
on the um Greyhound
um uh when I was weeping over getting
dumped by this guy in this band called
Dick's sister and I was a big sister yes
are they still a functioning band it's a
rap with dick sister but I was I was
with Dick's sister Dick's sister dumped
me I got on the Greyhound bus to go back
to Maryland on the weekend and I sat
next to this like lovely Bengali lady I
was weeping and I and she shared her
bagel with me and she was like you know
never cry for a man I never forget that
she said that she's like don't don't
give a man to her she's like come live
with me she said we can take marmalade
she remember she said that we could take
marmalade we'll take croissant in the
mornings we'll have a lovely life don't
cry for a magical don't give him tears
please this garbage person just come
live with me we'll take marmalade and
we'll take a we'll take yoga I was like
I'm gonna take marmalade and I want to
take yoga and just like have this
peaceful lovely life so I immediately
moved in with this sounds like she was
grooming you she perhaps she was yes we
I moved in with her and her family I was
just in this that's all it took isn't it
wild to think those relationships where
you were like this is the end of the
world yeah like I look back at the
people that in my 20s
up to like maybe 32 where the breakup
was so shattering yeah of someone that I
truly
if I saw them like at the grocery store
today
would not recognize them like like I
couldn't even tell you yeah on the floor
heaving in fetal position like I will
never get through this I had to have
friends take my phone so I would stop
texting take my car keys so I wouldn't
drive in the house and you're just like
that was like I was like unconscious
like I could not control myself like
that's how deep my abandonment wound was
the obsession like how badly I would
because you project so much onto them
like you think there's so much more than
they are just because they're
unavailable to you at that particular
moment like I would do that a lot with I
used to date you know cops I remembered
this FBI age and I was dating for a
while so imagine him coming home and
like throwing his gun in the sink like
just like everything I wasn't just some
guy that just fucking put hurled his gut
off and just sits there it's just hot
but also you're that I mean we're kind
of that like imagine seeing a girl go up
like grab a microphone and just be like
like kill promise there's not like a
supply and demand issue for a woman
doing that you know like no one's like
oh she's strong I want to get my mitts
on her I mean not enough there's a
certain amount of guys did you feel like
that like for me also and this is in New
York I guess like I don't know I think
that also in my 20s I was so not
protected as a kid like I just didn't
have you know it's like also there was
no concept of protecting children in
general like I would walk home from
school when I was like seven like can
you imagine
my mom had our number she was also
workaholic social worker
um very good person but just you know
also our moms were the first generation
if your mom did work the first
generation that got to go into the
workforce at all they had to work twice
as hard to get half as far imagine yeah
you're right imagine being so
unfulfilled for so long and then their
moms had to stay home and just like
drink Rose and cry and you know the
great part about it is because she did
that that's why I'm a workaholic like
that's why that's definitely I know
people ask me about my work ethic and
I'm like I wish I could like tell you I
did some trick I just watched a mom work
like so hard and she also loved her job
and it was so rewarding and fulfilling
for her and but it was that definitely
at the expense of of me a little bit in
some ways but how do you tell why
wouldn't you want the best for your mom
Mom and for her to be able to yeah she
would work her ass off I remember she
had like this one Maybelline eyeshadow
it was just like worn down you know just
like that Mom piece she was always
confused by it she's like what do I do
with them she look like dude remember
like like lipsticks of your aunts or
moms like the shape of the lipstick
would tell such a story like yeah like
my mom's lipstick would just be a blunt
Plateau like a square but I want Plateau
but my language was like a hard Choice
my aunts the way she put it on would be
like a Talon it'd be like almost like a
one of those quill pens yeah the way
that she put it on like just like you've
used this lipstick every day of your
life it didn't even hurt you to just buy
another fucking Maybelline eyeshadow mom
like she would wear even now she's
watching my daughter Frankie and she's
like I went to CVS and I couldn't find
this this Rouge that I have it comes out
of a tube and I was like there's a lot
of like liquid like you know cream
blushes I was like I'll just order you
one right now on Amazon I don't know
sweetheart it's a specific that it's it
comes from a tube I like that I'm like
there's a lot of two blushes there's a
couple you know myself uh like I am
hanging by a thread often and there is
like a certain lip color that holds
certainly together or a product and at
one time Chanel discontinued a lipstick
and I
like I believed it was like the reason I
was successful I believed it was the
reason the guy I was with was into me
like once again I was like I'm it's over
me too I do feel like I I like lack or
some sort of active lie precarious lie
on my face and if I'm not properly
lacquered and the truth will slowly
shine out are there things that you hold
on to like rituals or stuff that like
don't deserve to have as much weight but
for like cutting my cuticles like I am
addicted to cutting my cuticles I cut
them really horribly and I don't bite my
nails but I also dig into my ingrown
this is so gross I know dig into my
ingrown toenails and like to get and I
just it's like this maybe it's like a My
Strange Addiction thing but I feel like
if I've cut all my cuticles off I
can make it through the week right it's
just your little thing it's like your
little kind of vague like what is it
called
it's like a security blanket like this
one little thing that if I could do that
yes if I have two ponytail holders on my
wrist if I I can't leave the house if I
don't have them I'm like I can't this I
can't even like the little things that
you think are kind of holding you
together what is that called like a
crutch yeah a little crutches
a lot because um but I lose things so
much so I have a lot of things that I
would like to have but then I
immediately lose them but I also think
some of that's also probably comes from
the road because we just hurl our bodies
all over the country so much we don't
know where we're gonna be half the time
I'm like reading an email as I'm landing
and I'm just like okay Tamara's picking
me up and am I in Des Moines or Toledo
you know like you don't even know where
you are and so those little two ponytail
holders it's like well I got my two
ponytail holders around my wrist I'm
gonna be okay yeah I have these strange
little like minor things that because
there's sweet I mean it's really kind of
uprooting to travel as much as we have
to so just knowing that that one and
little thing is like something pleasing
it took me a long time to realize uh my
sister made me realize this the other
day because I feel like I've spent so
much time focusing on like our childhood
trauma like how to kind of do forensics
on it just like not to uh be a you know
just like crunch the numbers so that you
can utilize the information to move
forward this is why I do this it's not
my fault didn't do anything wrong like
got it cool I know how to like dismantle
this we're all doing exactly what we
were programmed to do unless you
actively deprogram all good whatever but
like I didn't even think about like
adult trauma that much like I was like
oh everything bad that happened happened
in the childhood and then adults like
whatever because like when something
traumatic when your adult happens you
can like reason it doesn't but like yo
when we would tour like there is so much
shit that happened on the road that I
have not even processed that I don't
know even how to because I also don't
want to complain I don't want to be seem
ungrateful but like there was a time
when I would do colleges and like just
Frack guys would pick me up in their
like Jeep Cherokee with no door
you know the ones with no doors yes I
know what you're talking about like like
you're on the freeway in Denver there's
like and then there's four like like
Denver Frat Boys in the back like
wearing like a no fear t-shirt that says
like 420 bro and they have a cool or
full of Coronas and they're like smoking
me and they want some weed I'm like
you're driving me in a car that doesn't
have doors and then you'd get to the the
college because every college game it's
like these different College whatever
it's awful I'm gonna just uh beg you to
elaborate on that I was just playing in
front of the I was really an obstruction
to this place they were making like hot
pockets and Tacos so and they put me
right in front of this thing so somebody
threw a taco at me because they were
pissed remember what college was
um I think I was at The Culinary
Institute of something in Las Vegas wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
have you played at The Culinary
Institute no how do you get that gig
well from a lot of networking you gotta
know I know the right people and I
obviously come for money I'm just saying
if you're at the culinary school don't
you value your culinary career
generational wealth that's how you get
it okay Whitney
no it's uh it's dark it's dark people um
I don't know how the fuck I got booked
at The Culinary Institute of Las Vegas
but I know that I got a fucking soft
taco thrown in my dumb can there that
I'll tell you what did you do what what
did you do I think there I wish that I
had this like big thing I said back to
the person but I think the taco just
sadly rolled off my tiddage and I just
kind of like collected myself and my
Paula Poundstone Blazer and just got on
with the fucking set and just kept
bombing I think what happened actually
is that I just softly continued to bomb
you just and then I said nothing at all
that I took a taco and then maybe I even
felt I deserved a taco you know maybe I
thought that it was all coming back to
me because it was all my fault
shining weather is sweet which means
sweat is upon us it's upon us it's
underneath us it's inside of us
thankfully Lumi deodorant is here to
keep us smelling nice when we need it
the most and where we need it the most
I'm talking pits privates and Beyond
let's face it our underarms aren't the
only place we have odor Lumi was created
by an OB GYN who discovered improved in
clinical testing that the vagina is not
to blame for day-to-day odor so she
developed Lumi a uniquely formulated ph
balanced deodorant it's aluminum free
skin safe and clinically proven to
control odor for up to 72 hours normal
deodorant just makes you smell worse and
makes you sweat more but this take a
lookie here okay I'm taking my shirt off
to make the point about putting
deodorant on Lumi look at this deodorant
by the way before I go on stage I put a
little between the crevices I put it on
my feet I put it between my toes I
sometimes put on the back of my neck and
by the time the second show rolls around
I mean I just smell like a quarry you
know like big Warf energy so thank you
Lumi Lumi starter pack is perfect for
new customers it comes with a solid
Stick deodorant cream tube deodorant two
free products of your choice like the
mini body wash and deodorant wipes I
love the deodorant wipes they're so good
and free shipping as a special offer for
listeners new customers get five dollars
off a Lumi starter pack with code win
that equates to over 40 off your starter
pack when you visit
lumide.com and use code WIC you know
it's also hot in my looking back not hot
now but in my early 20s in one of the
many train wreck relationships I was in
was just a man running after you to
apologize you know like just somebody
right no like just like like Marlon
Brando or that's what they say about
dating alcoholics and drug addicts Back
to Life Is So Young by the time I was
dating oh so embarrassing by the time I
was dating like hardcore drug addicts
and alcoholics
it kind of felt like being in a movie
yeah like excited because they're not
gonna remember the fight no but you get
to do like um uh uh War of the Roses was
one of my favorite movies growing up the
fact that I watched it is wildly
inappropriate um but we had like four
blockbuster movies that my brother never
returned and we watched them over and
over again and like
um A Few Good Men yeah scene with Demi
Moore and uh Tom Cruise was actually
shot like in Georgetown a block from
where I lived uh and I watched it when I
was a kid like live and like so I would
like these like drunk guys that like you
think you know whatever would start I'd
be like and then you and it like felt
like I was like in a movie yes but that
kind of drama is exciting when you're a
kid I feel like a lot of people feel
that way it is exciting it's like shit's
going down I feel like it's happening
practicing being an actress or something
because then you would like pass out and
I'd be like and also that's also kind of
what's shown to us at TV especially in
the really old movies in the 40s and I
used to talk about this on stage but
like there was always um a guy saying
something fresh to a woman and then the
woman would smack him and that seemed to
exciting so it's a fucking dramatic all
it is is like a drunk fight it's like a
chaotic drunken fucking I always thought
that was love too fighting was lovely
we're so passionate like I was like and
then I would like be like what am I
gonna throw I don't want to break
anything I don't have anything like I
don't have anything that's gonna one
time I did throw a wine bottle this is
bad I mean this was bad this was
actually not me just trying to be
dramatic and like feel like you really
threw it out of it and it's not like
fighting was like So Glamorous it is
it's a hot thing yeah in a movie I also
think that like as Comics like
you know we're Comics so yeah I would
always have these like great comebacks
you know what I mean yeah and like it
made me feel so like mic drop like I was
doing roast battle or something I just
need to become a comedian you know like
I remember one time this guy said to me
he's like you know what Whitney you're
just you're just like uh and I'm like
what a bitch a cunt what you know and
then he goes you're just like
you're just like a lot
yeah and then I and I was like this is
your chance bitch don't blow it because
it got so quiet like that is I know what
to respond to when a guy says you're a
bitch or a psycho you're crazy but like
you're just a lot I was like oh shit
he's gonna fucking win this and then I
just went it's just I and as soon as I
thought of it you know when you think of
a good joke you're like that's
satisfying what what just like and I
went well maybe
maybe you're just a little
oh it's good it's good and I literally
like and he's like it's done and I was
like
literally like went in my room
so stupid you know it's just like I
think it was just like you know I want
to be a writer I want to be an actress I
want to be a comic and like fighting
like that in your 20s like checks all
those boxes before people will pay you
to do it or let you do it professionally
yeah and people and like throwing in
shits going shit goes down like you're
in the middle of a story you know I
remember this guy screamed at me like he
was really mad at me about cooking and
he was like a hot meal every once in a
while would be would be nice a fucking
hot meal would be fucking nice and you
know what I do bacon chicken now and
again but I was fucking on the road a
lot then you know but he was always
angry about cooking it was such a funny
argument I mean it's so hacky just
really basic but people have screamed a
lot of um alarming and sometimes true
things and then not like what have you
done because you're in such a healthy
relationship now or I just really I just
mean like sorry I won't say healthy that
word is so annoying but just you know
um
I you you know Bonnie McFarland I see
Christina like I see female comics and
like marriages like stable marriages and
I'm just like what did you do like how
did you do it I mean I think I have a
hard time receiving love I think I have
a hard time thinking anyone could
actually love you know me giving what I
say on stage or if I'm with someone for
real I'm not going to be able to make
fun of like I don't know I have some
block about it like how did you
I mean when I got married we I mean my
relationship was pretty crazy then too
how did you know by the way this is the
guy because I have convinced myself I
have thought this is the one this is the
one and have been wrong so many times
and I'm like just don't say it don't
think it yeah I mean we've had a lot of
like wild you know horseshit and fights
and nonsense I mean we're in a bet at a
good place right now but I I think like
when I got married we were still in love
all kinds of like drama and and stuff
but I think um but that's actually
really helpful sorry I try to like yeah
like things don't have to be perfect in
order for you to get you know like
because I'm always like well I can't get
married past every red flag yeah I was
running out of time yeah but um I was
just like but no I mean I think now it's
it's it's better but um and now like you
have like a because you're so busy you
travel so much the people I know that
seem to have functioning relationships
carve time to like go on dates or talk
like for me I always get
uh I'm not good at telling someone what
my expectation is for tomorrow the next
day I'll be like why did you just do
that he's like I don't know I'm like
well you know I have this big day today
yeah and they're like not really and I'm
like well look at my calendar like I
mean do you have to like walk me through
like what you expect and what you need
emotionally or like yeah I mean my
husband emotionally he's pretty
worthless but he's I mean he's
definitely not like yeah I wouldn't say
that he's meeting my needs but I will
say this like that I get the met but no
he's like he's a firefighter you're
actually smart I think most people I
think it's delusional to think you can
get all your emotional needs met by
everyone like like but it's in a much
better place now like I'll get texts
from my husband that I know like I used
to fly and he wouldn't know that he was
like supposed to send a text like I
would you know like he is imagine if
your husband I talk about this on stage
too imagine if your husband was like
living at a firehouse for half the week
just five of his forget the firehouse
part just having sleepovers with like
five dumb guys I think that's helpful
for me no they undo like anything I
could have accomplished with them like
he comes home so much Dumber but when he
got married he's slowly he like
accelerated there's like an older guy at
his Firehouse that I think like teaches
and things because I'll get texts from
my husband and I'm like somebody told
him to write this text like he wrote
like safe flight my dear and I'm like I
don't see that coming out of Pete's
mouth naturally like somebody has a
white little lady yeah it's always
written like even his cards are written
like that like I'm like this isn't quite
how you're supposed to express this it's
a little bit like a sixth grade yearbook
my birthday cards would be like well one
marriage one baby and here we are I
couldn't have done it without you it's
like clearly who else was gonna burst
the baby shot GPT like is this an AI
rendition of like a husband loving the a
wife like this is broken English this is
appropriation frankly no it's always
like a weird like an impression of what
a husband should say but I will say this
my husband doesn't really like like lie
or try to be anybody so he's just like
that he just does what he does a big red
flag someone that's too charismatic I
mean Charisma is a red flag someone
that's too good at you know yes like
that charm machine and you're kind of
like I feel like you do this to everyone
this feels like manipulative that guy I
feel like that guy that says everything
you've been waiting to hear he either
wants to be inside of a man at the end
of the night he just wants to be safely
lodged in another man or he will make a
suit out of your skit like he is or like
like you read it and it's like it's I
think that's a Sam Smith lyric
yeah exactly like who did you get that
from
yeah like I'd rather it just feel like
authentic you know but that's kind of
fascinating to me you know be like
there's a couple things that really hit
me sideways that are it's so funny like
I was dating guy once and he texted me
um love ya and we never said I love you
and I was like yeah that's how he told
you for the first time
love ya and I was like was that like an
auto correct or like uh or is this are
you saying I love you for love yeah it
was just such a yeah I couldn't it took
me like a couple months to what did he
say did you speak well no did you say it
back
oh no I I thumbed up the text you thumbs
up and uh first I love you that's
fucking epic I always whenever guys says
I love you I always say thank you you
thank you is great thank you so much
like I like I don't love me so if you do
like like we have nothing in common
clearly like I know thank you is amazing
thank you like um so much it's also like
if you've known me for a year and
someone's like I love you I'm like well
you don't know me this you'll love the
person I pretended to be take it in wait
that's one step is take that in I have a
real hard time with that Michael I know
this is obnoxious but when I was growing
up like a lot of people I think feel
controlled by shame guilt money like
that word it was a lot of you know me
being upset as a child or me being upset
in relationships and people being like
but I love you I love you I love and it
was always a way to like calm you down
or I would hear I love you but like the
behavior didn't match it's like well if
someone loves it like I hate that yeah I
love you it's right after somebody like
shook me I feel like I love you at this
point just means shut up I love you I
love you and it's sort of like so my
thing is always I know this is like
bratty but I feel like that word has so
much power over me you know when someone
says I love you all of a sudden I have
to stay with you I'm not allowed I have
to say it back like you know I don't
like saying things that I haven't really
and I want to agree on a definition of
what love means before we say it like I
said this in a special which is like we
have to agree on a definition before we
say it well it is more of an action I do
feel like that that's what I was like I
would say I'll let you know when you
love me like I'll let you know like once
I feel it like I'll let you know the
last relationship like a year and a half
and I was like yo you love me because
you're acting like yeah because you just
like did something that I value because
it's like I am so weird in relationships
and what I value it's like it's really
like acts of service it's not words of
affirmation and it's kind of not
physical touch interesting yeah he's
he's acts of service too so that's what
I have to remember so my husband
boarded a plane without me once when we
weren't even fighting so he's
emotionally just like oblivious but so
like he'll do stuff like that where I'm
like what the fuck what the actual fuck
Pete and then he comes home and he just
has a groups of women screaming and I'm
picturing I'm picturing you you know the
what's the tunnel when you go onto the
fucking uh airport airplane like he's in
the front and you're like in the back
like just what the fuck is so funny and
I and then but he doesn't you can't get
him angry because he's got that even
first responder thing like so I'm like
what the fuck he's like I just figured I
got myself situated just like ludicrous
horseshit I've dealt with well I'm more
like your husband than I think maybe
than you because I I'm now I'm getting
worried because one time um I was flying
with this guy and we were going like on
a trip together and um we had separate
seats and he kept being like we'll try
to get our seats together and I was like
I'm like I feel like I just have so much
to get done and he's like it's so weird
for us to not sit together and I'm like
I feel like it's fine if he would be
happy as possible I just because then
you're kind of like I don't like when
people like you have your thing you have
all this I'm just like let's just
it's two hours he's good on his own too
but that I do think is the best part of
our relationship in a lot of ways at the
same time is because he gives me my
space he's like a New York
like you accidental feminist though like
he probably doesn't even really have a
he if I said feminist he'd probably be
like oh like one of those like Nazi type
people I don't know that really has God
but but it yeah it's over it it is I can
see that yeah people kind of like
militarize it but I mean what it
actually means just being equal with the
guy or whatever but if but he is like an
accidentally like that because he
doesn't you know he's never wanted me to
like like change my name or not do he's
not jealous he's not any of that stuff
because he loves his job right so
firefighters love their jobs and their
jobs are exciting so for stand-ups it's
a weirdly good match because it's like
he just they they live they work off
adrenaline they work weird fucking hours
he works on Christmas this time that
time we're also heroes yeah we're the
real heroes okay Master is the best
medicine and we I mean what would the
world do without our you know scrotum
jokes I don't know what they do without
this narcissist this one-loving
narcissist and a pink Blazer but he's no
he doesn't like um he's just accepting
he doesn't he doesn't leave a party and
like talk about people like he doesn't
there's never some second thing he's
thinking that you're like you find out
later nobody thinking is what he's
saying but that's often the problem I'm
so jealous of that though it's like when
like nothing drives me more nuts and
when you're just like you know and I've
done so much work with like prey animals
it's really helped me like working with
horses and watching herds and how they
interact like they'll if they have an
issue they'll bite at each other claim
their space let the other horse know
that they're uncomfortable and they move
on and it's over whereas like you know
the relations relationships where
something happens and like and then two
weeks later like and then you said that
in front of our friends two weeks ago
and I'm like
knotted statutes of limitations you
don't get to have seeds oh yeah he never
no you don't get to have some shit in
your back pocket from two weeks ago like
that shit drives me nuts because then I
can never trust you I feel like you're
keeping score I feel like I like you
know I like someone who's just like no
he holds on to nothing also because the
trauma that he's actually experience is
so much bigger than like me throwing my
ring at him when we were engaged or
something like that yes and I remember
like months later like twice by the
second time I was like all right wait a
minute the throwing things the one time
I did throw something in a fight because
it's like before you throw something you
got to make sure it's like not gonna
fuck up your house like an apartment at
the time but there was a brick wall and
this place in Philly and I was like I'm
gonna throw a bottle of wine I'm so mad
like and he had just walked through the
bottle of wine like right at the and
there was like a uh like a like a
grannity shitty Granite floor so I was
like this would be easy to clean up I'm
not gonna mess up a carpet like I had to
plan out my like you know
um involuntary I would rage yeah um
because I'd thought about it a couple
other times I'm like it's not time
[Music]
I throw it at the wall so hard
hits the ground does not break just
rolls off
and like literally he looks at me he's
like
and I was like that's not how I thought
that was gonna go like always so stupid
there's a sadness to a fall like that
it's so it's like I have a moment in a
fight where it's like you're like and
just like and then I was like he was
like that was so weird like yeah I don't
make a splash with my big moment but
yeah he was just like why didn't that
break I'm like I don't know I feel like
I threw it pretty hard and then he
picked it up and like he kind of threw
it and I was like this is crazy we
cannot that's I I thought that was gonna
I threw an ashtray once with a smiley
face on it and it was just and it would
it was the kind of glass that like
doesn't really break I like picked it up
and tried tried again I remember a guy
once being like just you have to just he
like helped me throw it it's the same
thing he's like you gotta angle it you
know take your Charming yourself yeah if
we're gonna get through this fight and
you're gonna be the mother of my kids
and you know you can throw an ashtray at
a fucking weirdo pedophile at the park
yeah but my husband like doesn't he he
does not
um he like he gives me a lot of space
and and that's what I get in return for
a guy that would board a plane without
me but he just absolutely is just like
you're doing your thing because he gets
they love he loves his job like they
love being firefighters there was like
they did something on like Bloomberg's
like top happiest workers or something
and one of them is fireman because they
get a lot of feedback you know what I
mean it's not like it's not like cops
and it was like marching against a you
know like firefighters yeah yeah it
would be nice there's like a herd of
people just angry at my husband it
wouldn't be a nice way to end an
argument like oh I guess those people
so it's also it's like I always say like
female comedians like we're kind of like
I mean I think things are like you know
it seems like with shows like whatever
hacks and maisel like everyone loves me
and mobile comedians as long as a female
comedian isn't actually in the show
um but uh there's like a thing of
fascination with us but I feel like for
the longest time like female Comics were
like the most hated species of person on
the planet like it just sort of because
I was so in my own thing of like God I
get a lot of hate like I get a lot of
this negativity online and then I
started sort of corroborating with other
female Comics I was like oh this isn't
just me it's kind of like I mean think
about the idea of a woman going on stage
that you have no chance of fucking just
complaining about men or her sex or all
the like triggering shit you know and
then to be with someone who's so
universally beloved yeah like it's just
it must be like completely so
frustrating like you slid down a pole
today like the fire wasn't that bad and
whatever he does people are just like
thank you for your service and then
whatever I do they're just like fucking
twat you know and I but I do think also
I read all my comments early on too and
I was really traumatized by them so like
when I was on Last Comic Standing and I
I um what year was like like it was
season seven I think I was on I can't
remember the exact day but so really
quick that was so crazy that that was a
show like I think about like comedy and
like how like
contests and comedy like hitting Comics
against each other it's already such a
hard thing like that makes like yeah
speaking of boats like what didn't they
put them I saw on a boat in one season
or something like what is this any of
this
no it's like how I quit my day job was
being on that show but then it was the
mental torture of going through all of
that weird shit and I remember reading
all the comments and I wasn't even able
to appreciate that I was like slowly
being able to do everything I kind of
dreamed of doing I started headlining I
wasn't opening on the road anymore but I
was reading all the comments and the
comments were just fucking brutal and I
was like I really didn't understand that
this was happening to like so many of us
but I was just like in my room every
night just like
sifting through I mean I did it to
myself I was just like the all hours of
the night just like so alarmed by how
much
um people really truly hated me and it's
not you know it's interesting because
like I mean my whole thing was negative
comments is I usually agree with most of
them I'm like good one good point they
do make some good points sometimes but I
also think it's like yeah the comments
thing is like I mean at the time like
that was like
sorry I'm like last night we had the
premiere of The Rose and I was screaming
um the entire night trying to get
everybody in La is on drugs everyone is
everyone thinks I'm on drugs I mean it's
like everyone's on Fentanyl and fucking
micro dosing mushrooms Whitney has
managed every aspect of this roast it's
fascinating I'm like you're you're the
one like color correcting and even at
the end of the night I was like texting
with you and you're like I gotta take
care of the vendors I'm like you're
paying the vendors yeah you're just like
you're tipping your pinks are like he's
she's paying somebody in cash for like
napkins
okay so Rachel every aspect Rachel
Feinstein as you know uh is on the roast
of Bert Kreischer I'm so psyched that
you did it like I'm like so psyched that
you said yes like because I was saying
when I did my roast I was like oh she'd
be great but we liked you know I was
like this might be a weird first time to
meet you like being on mine the Whitney
the roast of me comes out on Mother's
Day I just thought it'd be funny because
my mom's dead
um and uh we play some soft piano music
well by the way after you um uh have a
dad or mom die no one tells you like in
your calendar like when that day comes
up it's just you go to your counter just
says like Mother's Day and you're like
Jesus like you know you know what I mean
like those weird curveballs or like you
go on Instagram one day and it's all
like a photo of like your friend and her
mom on a beach in the late 80s and it's
like Mom I love you you did everything
for me it's like and you're like oh shit
I forgot like and now I'm dead moms and
dead Daddy's club like two days before
that I go like guys Mother's Day is
coming up get off your calendar get off
Instagram you know because it's just
like so blind signing so I thought it'd
be good to have something like you know
the Rose come out on that day so I'd
have a distraction but um uh but you you
doing Bert's roast was like such a good
mix because it was like Jim Norton and
and Jay oakerson it felt like there was
like this New York presence that I
really miss in like the LA sort of like
Vibe at the moment yeah but like how did
you feel about it uh
feel free to be critical as hell but
last night yes you are right I did
I did have to pay
um strippers 500 cash these girls from
crazy girls in La were in the lobby and
the guy that was like wrangling them the
manager from Crazy Girls comes up and
there are um you know because they were
just gonna walk around the party and
like kind of comedians are so awkward
like dancing I was like they'll just be
dancing it'll be good they'll be in the
only fans of TV bikini tops and I had
all this cash and I was like oh can they
come up we have room service whatever
and um he goes well I need the cash but
now but like they're not going to come
up until you pay them I was like jazz
why are we like doing everything and
also the text from you are always
amazing because I'll be like you always
answer because you'll answer like seven
questions that I didn't even know which
one I had because you're so you're so
like generous but and it's also just the
most random answers that you didn't know
you have like like come by my room I've
got clothes I've got jewelry and then I
get to Whitney's room there's like two
pigs in the bathtub she's just like get
your hair done in there you can meet the
pigs I'm like wait what what what's hat
what pigs there was just two adorable
fun-loving pigs in a bathtub she's like
yeah here's hair here's makeup here's a
bracelet I mean I need this shit believe
me I'm wearing one of the Jokers right
now I'm not above any of this I've
dressed myself in Whitney's Closet I'm
gonna be just like at night just
painting myself but it's really funny
because I'm like wait what happened wait
and nobody even explained the pigs there
was just two pigs in a bathtub in the
hotel you're just like come up you can
wear this light up bra there was like
some pink bra that like had like
antennas on it you were like whatever
you want babe and and say hi to the pigs
it's amazing can you explain this all of
that I just feel like this story is
really funny now in five years when I'm
on trial for grooming this story won't
be as funny it's like you have this
amazing she has this like Rachel in the
burger Chrysler Rose has some of my
favorite drugs but one of them is like
so serious because like during the
pandemic it was like you know there you
guys all saw you know a lot of comics
like you know in La I mean to not be
able to do Stand Up or On TV or or in
any capacity or in clubs for two years
so many of these Comics that didn't have
TV credits or were just about to do
Fallon are just about to do whatever
um uh like we're screwed you know and
like like you know with all the mental
health challenges we already have like I
just so we started doing shows in my
backyard and I started and I really
never got to be friends with female
Comics like just for whatever reason I
was jealous of those goddamn backyard
shows I was just rocking in my Nikon in
Brooklyn like I would be that fucking
The Grotto having all these like female
Comics Over You know guys too whatever
and then but but I mean I see now from
uh if I had seen it on Instagram and it
was someone else I mean your joke was
funny you were like what is going on
like what's going on at your house it's
like it was just so simple like
I've been watching it for like four
months straight in editing it makes me
laugh every time you're like you just
have a bunch of female Comics over at
your Grotto there's always like somebody
doing like a whore crawl at Whitney's
Grotto that she's like freshly painted
but this is all the shit I love I like
trying on like tidditch tops like you
make them pose for awkward photo shoots
like there's always somebody in that
pond but then I also want to be there
I'm like I want to be standing on that
fucking rock thing and there was
something similar to inner tube or
something Whitney I love you I do but
what the fuck is going on at your house
like what's happening there's this weird
like Barbie Dream Home full of young
female Comics you hand like props to and
force into uncomfortable photo shoots
there's always like an open Micah doing
like a whore crawl and a stand-up paddle
board and Whitney's Grotto you're like
the jelaine Maxwell of female comedy
I put Taylor Tomlinson on this side
table in the pool and she stood on it I
was about to take a picture and then it
like crashed I mean it was it was a Etsy
purchase it was I should have maybe
checked the you know
um the sturdiness of it it like crashed
in like I thought I was supposed to give
oh my God if I like break Taylor
Tomlinson's leg the story is gonna be
like Whitney is the Tanya Harding of
Comedy she takes out any comedian who's
getting successful it just looked like I
was like injuring young guys I was like
nothing from an 80s film I saw that
crash yeah I was just sitting there like
yeah just freshly giving birth just
rocking my nightgown on Instagram just
like oh they're in fucking grottos in
L.A it stunk up Brooklyn it was really
stunk it up back there I was doing shows
in people's backyards I remember doing a
show and this woman was just like she
goes whatever you do she I was just in
somebody's backyard like me and like Sam
Morrell and a couple other comics and
just her fucking back patio and somebody
goes listen whatever you do just don't
talk to the girl with the bright blue
hair that's screaming about the
patriarchy and I'm like can we just kick
her out and somebody was like it's her
house
well I had bright blue hair but I don't
talk about the patriarch I don't give a
shit but but yeah I mean I think like I
was
um I wanted to be in that Grotto and I
also always wanted somebody to coax me
into wearing some outfit like I'm the
one who puts on the hori outfits myself
no one's ever like I'm never like I
guess so I guess I'll try on this you
know I've always wanted somebody also
wanted like a director to like push me
to play the guitar everybody's like
we're good you know like I've never got
to have sleepovers when I was a kid
because I always had freaking head lice
is that a common trauma I feel like I
don't know I was like not allowed to go
to sleepovers and stuff consistent head
lice I really feel for you because
something was going awry I like I like
wet the bed and there were some other
issues but an ongoing life situation I
mean that is not that is not your
fucking fun like that's not good I feel
no I would get sent to the nurse I would
be sitting in school like at a desk you
know those desks that were like
connected to the chair and you'd have to
like get into it and I'd be like sitting
because I would always like lean forward
and I would like see a lot lice bug like
fall onto the desk and I would kill it
with my nail I would just go like like
that like it was crazy they had to like
cut my hair we just you have to when you
have head lice you have to wash all the
sheets in hot water you have to vacuum
nobody did that nobody could get it no
there was no one around to do something
like a fucking wash you that's why
you're washing others now because you
should have been washed you're not just
washing you're brushing them and making
what I do anytime a girl comes to my
house she has to go in the chlorine
filled pool first the photo shoots are
just a trick every just in case I'm so
traumatized by headlights but I'm
obsessed with this like that would be
amazing if I got here and somebody like
sanitized me and there was just a woman
like checking my scalp before I did
Whitney's podcast
um so tell me about the roast experience
how it was I hope I wasn't too
overbearing because I think for me I've
been doing this like you two long enough
to where but I was I always said by the
time I'm in charge I'm always gonna like
make it so people don't have to ask for
things that would make them feel like
divas or make them you know because like
I feel like you know as a as a gal for
now in this business like I would show
up to Rose to show up to you know comedy
clubs or whatever and because they're
used to mostly dealing with dudes if I'm
like hey could someone like run out and
get me tampons or hey can I just like
get like my own space whatever to change
like I always felt like I was always
asking too much and so by the time I'm
running you know this roast I want to go
like here's the deal like this is all
happening there's hair there's makeup
like you don't have to worry about
anything because especially as female
Comics they'll be like can I have care
and makeup it's like oh my God it makes
you feel so those little things
especially and I want to look pretty yes
I do I do yeah I look like Steve Buscemi
without a little caulking grout under
the eyes like can I it's like ask for
the lighting to be better if I go into
someone's podcast and I'm like hey can
we maybe like does this have to look
like we're telling ghost stories by a
fucking fireplace like do I really need
my face to look like the Grand Canyon at
this angle you know so that stuff is so
nice because nobody's thinking about
that stuff yeah like but also if someone
is like for me I know when the lighting
is on point and like I have whatever
makeup makes me feel strong like my
performance is better yeah you have the
space to do your job you're not worried
about whether
um yeah you somebody for me that
somebody can see my like cheek acne scar
or something yeah but it's like figuring
out like with every roaster like we all
have our insecurity like the thing we
need to perform at our best so it's like
with Norton and I was like oh Norton
having his girl there like we got to
make sure he's got his girl there do you
know what I mean yeah Donnell like he's
just got to make sure there's 15 bottles
of Hennessy and no girls that he's
dating there uh you know and like
figuring out what everyone needs to feel
like they can just fly very like
personal little collection with us it's
always like can someone just be watching
my hair so I don't have to think about
it yeah that's definitely for me true
like definitely I want to know that I
don't like that I'm not going to be like
haunted by my arm fat in a dress or that
somebody will tell me if something's not
flattering because later on and then
later on it won't be like just deeply
distracted because I had some sort of I
don't know aggressive cellulite or
something or some slab that I didn't
realize I had hanging out was there
anything that her hurt your feelings
because I really tried to do like and
you know any answer is okay okay because
I was like here are my rules no saying a
woman that is like 40 is old because I
remember when we first started doing
mine they'd be like Whitney soul and I'm
like do you guys think I'm old I'm like
no and I'm like well then what are you
doing they're like well it's just this
is I'm like stop stop like copying like
the old Comedy Central roasts that like
always felt a little bit cringy like
let's just like do something fresh and
like let's make sure it's true you know
and then no saying that um guys are like
creepy pedophiles if they're not because
there are creepy pedophiles in our
business so it's not like I didn't want
to put you don't want to get a file
rumor started and I don't have files to
go around you may as well direct them
towards the right file of pedophiles
yeah I'm saying like but I also didn't
want them those are good um like real
racism no uh uh like homophobia that's
just like cheap like the joke just has
to be smart yeah and less obvious my
biggest pet peeve of no saying Comics
aren't funny that drives me nuts or that
they're not successful in their career
it's like anyone here is like the best
of the best so like those were kind of
like the rules but I'm sure okay
um it's easy I mean you're gonna get
your feelings hurt sometimes I can say
that doesn't hurt my feelings but yeah I
guess probably one of the ones that I
thought was an excellent joke but now
it's just probably one of the best jokes
I've heard in a long time was Zach Amico
who who said that Rachel had a
children's book
it's called he said Rachel's a mother
now she has a children's book and it's
called the dog that saved Hanukkah about
herself and I was like that is one of
the funniest things first of all I want
to read that children's book I want to
know about the dog that saved Hanukkah
and all his adventures does everybody
want to know about the dog in Jeopardy
but I know what it really wasn't any
steaks I feel like it does well every
year that was happening that somebody
wasn't going to be able to gently light
a menorah it's not really a difficult
activity yeah it's kind of all there
right in your kitchen usually there's
candles and some matches in a drawer I
love that all the wacky things that
would have happened that the dog would
have had to run along some fucking
collie would have had to say I don't
know if a lot of Hardcore Jewish people
that have dogs such a good joke it's so
funny but I was like I called I
definitely called a few friends and I'm
like wait if I always been the dog that
saved Hanukkah and no one's told me till
now like I've always just been
lipsticking myself and going out like
you're welcome and not realize that
everybody sees me like the dog at the
same time when you but it's also not not
everybody sees you that way I think it's
more like I think it's actually the
opposite having been in room so much you
can only call a beautiful woman a dog do
you know what I mean it's like it's like
calling it's like calling someone a
retard is only funny if they're not they
don't have Down syndrome right you know
what I'm saying so it's like that so
it's like but it still sucks because
when um you know I first started and
everyone's such a good joke though but
for me it was more like you know because
I mean look everyone's got notes on my
face like it really stresses everybody
out but I've said everything I've done
like I've done Botox right around my
eyes here I've gotten boobs obviously
and like so for myro's Dan says
something so funny Dan Levy said
something so funny it was about um uh
Hannah stocking who hosts mine the
influencer I really wanted to like mix
like like digital comedy creators that
are really big and comedians that from
traditional media and like you know
there's this thing of folk tick talkers
and screw like Instagram comedians like
whatever if we were 25 we'd be doing
that you know I'm trying to like like
blend them and like no that's cool also
you you never know who's gonna be funny
like when you're asking about the like
sometimes people are surprisingly funny
that you think that you think oh well
they had this was easier but there's a
lot of different weird mediums that
produce hysterical people like
um speaking of your early um influences
being Dennis Rodman you know what show
was so fucking funny was inside the NBA
that show was so funny when I was I
don't think I ever saw it they would
just give each other shit they would
trash each other like Comics like like
like broccoli would be wearing tube
socks or something and Shaq would be
like why are you wearing those dumps
yeah athletes are so funny that show is
fucking funny they were just trashy all
they do was roast each other so Blake
Griffin was in a movie that I made so
funny and I was like why are you so
funny he's like all basketball players
and football players are fine because
all we do is roast each other in the
locker room so hard and then all we know
on the road is watch Comedy Central
Chappelle Show Will Ferrell movies and
they get the timing down uh Blake
Griffin actually did stand up in
Montreal once it was Jimmy it was like
legitimately funny not even like just
for a basketball player yeah yeah I've
heard he's really funny too he's pretty
hot I was dating in New York Jet once
and I was hanging out with him and a
bunch of his friends I wish I could
start a sentence like that I was dating
New York Jet once and it did I mean look
it didn't we met a Dancing with the
Stars it didn't go great it was it's
longer a conversation look I I was
literally rebounding oh no that's
football never mind uh uh wait no what
are you doing when you rebounding his
mask well how would you I was I remember
guy dummy ones that I was just imagining
like I was fantasizing about getting him
back somehow or some situation to make
him jealous and I was just like I want
to date a fucking New York Jet that's
what I did I want to be sitting in the
stands just like gently stacking
snacking on something and him looking up
at me and giving me like a huh you know
like if you'd be like go get him babe
I like to do that I go to like the
Knicks game with like Sam or like some
comics and I'll be in the front just
like I went with the baby wasn't I was
just in the front just being like beep
beep taco night like just some guy that
doesn't know me at all like babe
remember date night babe I do that to my
husband I just follow but I'll find like
the most violently unattractive guy at a
park like somebody that's like homeless
like spitting in a trash can and I'll be
like babe babe are we doing an early
dinner tonight babe he's like I'm over
here like it'll just be some guys like
just almost dead with just a needle just
dangling out of his arm and I'm like
babe anniversary you know
I was definitely dating this guy to make
the other guy jealous and it didn't work
I think it made him feel incredibly
sorry for me
um but uh oh and we were like hanging
out with a bunch of like his like
friends and like like like you know like
all of the uh athletes like uh
girlfriends and stuff and one time he
said something it was like um oh uh you
know because all the athletes are so
injured like when you date a football
player and you see all the stuff that
happened I mean he like
you know their bodies are just destroyed
like the amount of like they give them
like all like like Adderall and like all
the stuff and just like Jack them up
with stuff and like you know this is the
CTE stuff it's like the concussion if
you have three concussions that's my
type though freshly contained
let me nurse
had a fucking stranger at a bar how
about fresh concoction fucking stick it
in and then to pull it out method yeah
we'll do the pull it out method but no
by the way we both sound like two old
ladies in a nursing home who have
emphysema like why are we both talking
like I have lost my voice I've not had
every comment speaking of reading the
comments every comment under my YouTube
videos is always like man voice she
sounds like like a dude that smoked
three packs of cigarettes so don't even
need to write that because I know and I
don't know why I do sound like I've just
like I sound like I've had a fucking
rough go I don't know what it is I
remember when I first did a TV show
there were like three or four comments
uh uh what are they called a journalist
who did pieces on me that talked about
like the show's really like funny and
smart whatever but it's hard to get past
her shrill voice and like you could
never do that today there's literally a
show called shrill whatever but I
remember it's like the ouch wow somebody
has to fucking hover over her listen to
that voice well you know what fuck you
because I know my voice stinks they were
like she has big teeth it was like every
single thing they hit me on it was only
things I couldn't change about myself
yeah I was a real hostile voice she's
like a real kind of General take charge
Voice Even after shows like nobody ever
hits on me after shows if anything I get
like a pound like a good shit like
somebody kind of rocks me a little too
hard or something like that I never just
did this is also by the way I feel like
now that everyone is like so worried in
like the work places to be like sexually
harassing intern or a woman by accident
every time I'm like you know uh at work
or taking photos for press or something
like any man like uh that fox show I did
um we were on the Press line with Howard
Gordon uh and uh you know it's like all
these guy producers and I'm staying with
them and everyone's so afraid to like
touch someone's lower back or touch a
woman that when they see it they'll give
you this hug and like smack you on the
back and you're like okay I feel like
that's how my dad hugs anyway just
because he's like so emotionally from
the side butterfly hit even even on my
wedding day like he never said I love
you she's like oh okay I'll be like I
love you Daddy goes all right and I get
a weird butterfly side they're just
doing the like heimlich no on my way he
was like rushing me down the aisle I was
like are you doing something after this
he was like all right we gotta go come
on just somewhere to be he was he's
always got that anxiety when he's ever
on his way anywhere I'm like this time
Dad it's not that Vibe I had to like I
had to position his hand like where it
should be on my back and be like we walk
a little slower but I was like come on
let's go
can I ask you uh your wedding day was it
like everything you wanted it to be did
you did your brain break so many women I
know his brain just breaks I had a lot
of fun on my wedding day I I um it was a
shit show I mean we got married in
fucking Staten Island because Pete was
like insisted we got married there
because he had like a hook up there or
something it was all comics and
firefighters there's a senior frog that
had a get a Groupon uh cheesecake so
ludicrous we had it was like um Colin
Quinn and Tom Papa did the ceremony I
was not in any way like a bride like I
do wish that I'd maybe been a little
more and I just like would stop and be
like look at the dress I'm wearing like
I'm wearing this dress ridiculous
foolishness was it hard to pick a dress
I picked a dress and um yeah it was kind
of hard I I don't love the way I look so
my wedding day um but uh I don't do
white I like I would not do a white
wedding dress I would like to go back
and do something more interesting and
like yeah you're not crazy about how I
look but um I could throw another
wedding and just have all my friends but
we have why can't you I mean I guess I
could wear a wedding dress but I don't
invite people for me to renew my dumb
vowels it's just like a do-over like
just like do-over I just want to get
some better photos like I did a laser
recently like I just want to redo my
wedding five years after it I could just
like a part it can be like your five
year anniversary party and we could put
on a dumb dress or something yeah why
not I mean but it was fun we had a lot
of fun that night it was a it was a
complete shit show my parents my dad's
speech my mom is like aggressively
liberal and my dad's speech was like
about immigration I think he he was like
talked about immigration policies he's a
civil rights lawyer but he didn't
mention like me or Pete his speech was
like mostly about immigration like grab
the mic at the end of the night and he's
like Trump 20 20 and it just fell over
but it was a fun fucking shit show one
of my friends uh fucked a firefighter
that night it was just and the next day
she was like asking the next day when
she peed yeah she was like did did we do
it I've had this happen twice two of my
friends she was like did can you find
out if if I did anal with this guy I was
like first of all if you think you might
have done anal you did anal yeah don't
you unless you do anal a lot I feel like
the next day you kind of know you know
you're like if anal's even on the
fucking table yes you analed you
wouldn't feel it I feel like you'd feel
it and also how was I supposed to follow
up on that I love that I was like on my
honeymoon she's like can you find out if
I did anal did you go where'd you go we
went to Bora Bora because Pete got like
it through Costco my husband's obsessed
with Costco so we got like we
honeymooned through Costco we got like a
Costco bus and we got it to Bora Bora
wait wait he's like we can mate all the
Costco Shoppers just like us I'm like
that's not what the honeymoon is about
it's like networking he's like but they
all love Costco but we got we eventually
taking on an additional Mormon wife
because I'm obsessed with him wait he's
Costco for Costco Costco had a Bora Bora
trip is a for sale he has all his truck
he likes to book his travel through
Costco and he also was like I've never
heard of this he traveled across go just
travel and my husband didn't shed a tear
at our wedding but it was strangely
emotional when I got an executive
membership to Costco he was like weeping
I'm not gonna get tears I was like a big
moment not just a member you're an
executive member jeans really yeah they
have good jeans there we I guess they
handle every aspect of the travel and
you could book travel through Costco in
these little vacations and so we went to
Bora Bora we did end up in one of those
little houses on in the water which was
lovely but before that we were like
herded onto like a boat and there was a
lot of other sort of like Costco
mingling that my husband was doing he
also goes like this he actually makes
the the gun at people they're like hey
Casco executive Mama are you gunning
people what the fuck are you doing he
was gutting people you could know
somebody on this ship or Bora Bora yay
how's it going yeah that's what I will
say if you are if you are on like the
Costco boat to the thing you already
have so much in common with everyone
like normally when you go on a trip and
like everyone's going to the same place
you're like like we're all going to the
same place but we have nothing in common
I'm sorry but when you're all like we're
the Costco people like I already if you
have a Costco membership I already fuck
with you yes like we already share the
same beliefs too that's amazing I just
feel like when you can find like a
common ground with people that you're on
an awkward bus with it's like Costco is
a great way to connect no if I want to
butter my husband up I mentioned
something about Costco or ask him a
question about what he got at Costco
like most women like blow their husbands
or something if they want them to do
something for them or give them some
money or something I just ask them about
Costco I'm just like that was Kirkland
it's a whole like it is a community it's
like it's a that's what he said to me
right before he proposed he's like you
know it's a community it really is and I
think we should honeymoon through Costco
it's very important there's also people
that use the brains they think ahead
like they don't want to pay like a
ridiculous amount of money for like I
liked it I like someone that um
what's the word it's just like if you
have your Costco card I like your value
system you don't believe you should have
to pay uh more than something uh is
because it's what because when you buy
in bulk it's gonna be cheaper you also
believe like and Men love bulk they're
always right before you buy 10 boxes of
those Bagel Bites like I deserve to try
them yeah I do love the free snacks I
love a free snack that is very
delightful I know I have to get you out
soon only fans roast is airing now on
oftv it is free don't be annoying about
it you do not have to have a profile to
watch it are you touring yes Rachel
feinstein.com go to my website Rachel
feinstein.com and all my tour dates are
up there I love you guys and these
awkwardly don't ride elephants
[Music]
thank you